poi risponde favi iniziali do facendo
vedere la tua maglia preferita ragazzi
questa questa che ho addosso e la maglia
che preferisco in assoluto dei pronti
per che dovette amarla perché è
bellissima io io io ci andrei veramente
in giro così perché peter vince tutto l
a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono fa vj e quella è una foca
[Musica]
come ogni sabato ragazzi siamo in un
nuovo blog prima di cominciare ad
iniziare con la fan art e la settimana
che questa settimana è stata vinta da
benni che ha fatto sto disegno ci ha
messo tutti ragazza l'altro anche il
tizio di aulas che sempre più fiducia me
lo ricordavo meno gnocco ma lo è di più
non ragazzini ribassare degli usa anche
se non ne ho tante oggi miracolo anche
stavolta che non so news è strana e
veramente strano sa cosa non me lo state
chiedendo tutti visto che sperimenti ho
iniziato a mettere ogni tre quattro
giorni una foto nuova su instagram
perché lo sto usando di più
volevo dirvi ragazzi che lui l'unico
profilo mia persona
miu miu miu miu instagram è questo qui
c'è fa vj e basta non fare solo fa vj
quindi se vedete altri profili da
qualche altra parte non so dove sono
tutti ferito perché se con vi arrivano 2
miliardi di messaggi al giorno che mi
chiedono questo è il tuo profilo questo
no no io io c'ho questo no no no la foca
il profilo ecco anche ragazzi è iniziato
minchia schiacciato una mosca senza
uccisa se non lo giuro che non volevo
lug i ragazzi ho finito con le news inc
non so perché vinciamo così poche news
ma va bene così meglio che possiamo
passare allo scarso dei fatti che non sa
perché oggi mi sono mi sento buone ne
apro 4 e come vuol dire anche host
ragazzi mi sono dimenticato di dirlo ma
sentite questa ho chiuso punto posta un
po di tempo fa quindi non mi arrivano
più pativa che devo devo aprire quelli
che ciò perché sono definisco più ero
andato tipo un mese fa la posta a
ritirare tutte le lettere che mi erano
arrivate non i pacchi le lettere quale
le lettere e le ho messe tutte in un
forziere perché non ci stavano da
nessuna parte adesso vi faccio vedere
quante cazzo sono preparatevi
[Musica]
chi sa sono castrato siete pronti
ragazzi
così non vi rendete conto di quante sono
in realtà ora me ne rovescio addosso
così potete capire un attimo
[Musica]
più che ragazzi questo per farvi capire
che c'è un miliardo di lettere da
leggere quindi rimarrà mandata non si
incavoli sono la leggo subito a mare
sono un miliardo non sfrutta fini
infatti nel caso ve lo steste chiedendo
è una foca ce l'ho fatta e la prima
volta nella storia che non mi cascano
questo è un giorno a ricordarmi riempito
di gioia ogni volta lega che veramente
siete una soddisfazione tratto qua hanno
scritto 10.000 volte favi non sarà
capito che era permesso pochi ragazzi
questo cos'è cos'è stato cos'è c'è un
morto qua dentro ho paura di aprirlo
però troppo trovato una panart
bellissima io sono inquietante da morire
se sono altri coriandoli vi ammazzo io
t9 questa rai il pupazzetto di pacman
basta chiunque tu sia io ti troverò è ti
sposerò credito cosa qualcosa perché
perché spiegami perchè questa faccio
fatica a capirla crei credetemi come
morbida che figo e poi ce so è
un'espressione bellissimo con chi
ragazzi questo lo riciclo per per natale
perché non si sa mai
oh mio dio si vabbè ma rega ma siete
pazzi bellissimo ma questa è la versione
maxi mio zio dato non c'è nutella sono
comin cos'è sta cosa c'è una patata coi
capelli
[Musica]
si no che figo perché questo è
bellissimo è la cosa più dado mi spunta
un ciuffo a caso dell ama da sempre
sempre più sexy ragazzi sempre più sexy
ma proclami inviate queste cose ragazzi
l'invenzione del secolo sono un ragazzo
felice guarda sotto ma perché da questo
è è un parco troll non capiti siamo
regalo
ciuccio un ciuccio direi che possiamo
passare al fa vi risponde perché sono
leggermente incazzato tra l'altro c'è
ancora la foca morta sul letto
bellissimo la prima domanda ragazzino
incorniciata perché intelligentissima
eugenio maria de rosa complimenti per il
nome amico mio innanzitutto vi risponde
ma tu fai l'amore con il sapore asi
eugenio maria de rosa giulio di kardon
montoya della rosa ramires
sì lo faccio poi risponde guardati un
video di tela piccolo se se lo hai e
commentato in diretta che sta già ride
senza aver visto niente
a prescindere o mio dio rega o mio dio
cos'è sta cosa questa è violenza di
palloncini che faccio non so perché i
ragazzi io c'ho ancora paura dei
palloncini nel senso che mi fanno paura
perché ho paura che esplodano elimini
mangiavo a caso con la bocca e togliere
ai spia in spiaggia era un figo da io
ero il figo della spiaggia che non solo
c'è dubbio però franchi fatti vedere da
papa come stai bene che mi stanno dando
per gli occhiali così cose uno sponsor
viene venduto non l'ho capito ma che
faccio ma no perché perché ragazzi è la
casa o mio dio li ho messi bene ragazzi
questa questa una scena che passa alla
storia
tenetevi pronti
[Musica]
e cioè della figaggine in queste cose
no ma vorrei come s'atteggia qualcuno se
la tira sto maledetto ecco come ha
conosciuto un mondo dei video che c'era
un motivo alla fine avevamo visto una
figlia forse mia mamma quello che lo
faccio perché non perché ragazzi
adrenalina a mille
basta che è stato è stato tragico
comunque swag sono texan favi ahimé
ricevuto la targa da un milione gli
scritti di youtube diretto ragazzino non
l'ho ancora ricevuta io c'ho quella da
100.000 che l'andata con tutti quelli
che hanno soprattutto 100 mila iscritti
mi manca il gol che sarebbe ce l'ho
appesa map è questa ecco così abbiamo
siete contenti temi ma è quella da un
milione che la danno a chi ha raggiunto
un milione per ogni data e non lo so
quando mi arriva quando mi arriva farò
tipo la life pongo fuori dalla finti
paul papa mentre la finestra così ha
comunque va bene cosa ragazzi dopo
queste bellissime figure di merda posso
concludere il video qua da michela
fallito ma mi sto dimenticando affari
domanda ma voi vi domanda qual è il
vostro personaggio preferito di libri
film qualsiasi cosa
il mio il mio è dentro queste ragazzine
che posso concludere quel video come al
solito ragazze il video è piaciuto
lasciate un commento mi piace anche a
pagina di facebook e come miglio
trattenne descrizione se non sapresti di
stile felici diventavano prossimo video
delle ragazze